The joe rogan experience.
No,
he's not being mean.
I stopped doing racial jokes,
like being heavy on racial jokes just cause I was like,
I don't fucking know.
I don't,
I don't care.
Like I don't give a shit enough about equality to put my job on the line to try
to make everyone even like I'll,
I'll get into nights if it's an all black room.
I just do black jokes but not mean,
but just what I do.
Black jokes.
But um,
and then you do that.
Once you do that,
you have a fucking power of attorney to do anything.
Cause even the clean people go my kid's finger,
they're asked to write right now and then,
and then,
and then I talked to the audience a little when you were saying that you,
um,
you used to do a real racist jokes or racial jokes,
racial jokes,
you know,
w you and you stopped doing them because they offended too many people.
No,
I never gotten,
no one ever got offended,
but I just noticed that I was up for one.
I was obsessing on it.
I can,
I would write,
I could write all day long.
I could write jokes about black people.
I mean,
if you've sent me,
I swear to God,
if you put me in a room with a black audience,
all I'll do is talk about black people all I'll do.
And like now the dirt,
the one only the furthest I go is I have a joke about,
um,
just,
uh,
I go,
I think is racist that they don't make black baby powder.
Like,
I just think that from a company named Johnson and Johnson,
they would have thought of that by now.
And then they go,
you know that,
uh,
that's home and make $1 million.
I'm gonna make by baby powder.
And then,
uh,
and then,
and then I'll call it magic Johnson and Johnson's.
So then one night there's one,
this is great.
One night this black dude's,
it's of an audience in Miami.
He goes,
hey motherfucker,
when you get done,
you did a joke about black baby powder.
I'll tell you I don't make shit.
And so I was like,
I'm think I'm done with a joke now.
Like with,
why don't they make it?
And he goes,
we don't have a problem with moisture the way you guys do it goes.
Every time I hung a white guy,
it's like hugging a dolphin.
He goes,
black people have a problem retaining moisture.
So they have a problems getting ashy so they have to always stay moist.
Whereas white people are constantly fucking moist.
Whoa.
And so he's like,
they just never needed black baby powder like people don't use.
And I was like,
but it was awesome.
It was like a great moment.
I love dude,
if I could,
if I had a video tape of every experience that I'm a black to in London
audience,
I would be the most famous comic in the world.
The,
I've had black dudes get on stage in Miami,
right?
Real Shit.
Fucking three gangsters in the front row.
True Story.
All my children fucking,
they're ruining the show for everyone.
And I go up and I just talked to them one day.
He gets up on stage half a through my set and he's like,
this is a real motherfucker.
He's keeping it real,
real talk right now.
Real talk,
you know,
real motherfuckers getting at three Oh five and he drops his pants and shows his
Dick Place goes bananas,
right?
They're like,
whoa.
And it's a the biggest blackest.
It's almost purple.
It's so black like,
but as jack huge,
it's huge.
And I'm like,
that isn't real.
That is bugging real bugging month nine inches.
And it's a,
it's a,
it's a shower.
It's like a thick,
thick,
thick and uncircumcised.
Just looking at it like,
Holy Shit.
So then I go,
I go,
man,
that's fucking,
his name was ray.
I don't know why I remember that.
But I'm like,
Ray,
I go,
I think you might want to get off stage because I can guarantee you they're
calling the cops right now and I don't want you to go to jail for just showing
your Dick.
He's like,
I appreciate that.
Good looking out.
And then he puts his pants on and leave.
So then I go,
man,
how do you follow that?
Another gang banger stands up,
gets on stage.
I go,
please tell me.
We're seeing another cock right now.
Pulls his pants down,
bugging justice.
Big But lighter,
lighter,
like a lighter brown.
And I'm like,
Holy Shit.
I'm like,
and I was like,
you might want to go catch up with breaks.
I can't guarantee you they're calling the cops now.
So they're sitting with,
I swear to you,
all my children,
they're sitting with an heroin,
a hairless albino.
Okay.
And I said,
and now and now that the crowd is like fucking in a fevered pitch.
I go,
that's funny.
Out of all the Dicks,
I wanted to see what was yours.
He stands up,
gets on stage,
takes his dick out and it looks like a light house.
There's no grass,
right?
White and the Po,
they're flipping over fucking tables now.
Like fucking going nuts.
And I was like,
Ladies and gentlemen,
that's my show.
That's it.
Oh,
I literally followed that.
You can't follow that.
Can't follow it.
I literally,
and I've white glow in the dark Casper that goes Dick.
Oh was,
it was beautiful and it was big.
It was big.
I swear to you.
And I was like,
oh,
I was like fucking and then and then they all waited for me out at the bar and
they were like,
dude,
we're taking you out.
And I was like,
this doesn't end this way.
I love it when he bombs
so rare.
He's really fucking funny man.
It's like when it's like when you shoot a bear with a bow and Arrow,
but they don't know they've been injured yet,
but they know there has to be shot with a bow and arrow.
I watched a lot of hunting.
I watched a lot of hunting videos like I used to.
I used to,
if I,
if I ever got too fucked up within,
I'd watch hunting.
In Florida,
it's very easy to get really bear bear hunting from,
in my opinion,
you've done it.
I've never done it,
but all the videos are,
they like put a box out full of food and then they'd sit in a tent and then the
bear would come out and they shoot it with a bow and Arrow and the bear would
get hit.
But it would almost feel,
it would seem like the bear be like,
ow,
what the fuck was that?
And then you'd see the look in the bear's face where they'd be like,
I don't feel good.
I'm going to go rest for a little bit.
That's how Supergirl girl looks.
When he bombs.
It's like,
it's like,
he's like,
he like,
he looks at you like,
did I get,
I get hit?
And you're like,
and you're,
and you know,
he's been hit by an arrow.
My favorite one was in,
uh,
in,
in Pearl Harbor.
Me,
Pearl Harbor,
Hawaii,
me,
Tom Segura and Russell Peters.
And,
uh,
I go up and I do okay,
but maybe I was dirtier than I should've been,
but it's totally fine.
Cause the only rule thing,
we're don't make fun of the Hawaiians.
That was,
it don't make fun of the Hawaiians.
And don't bring up Pearl Harbor.
What?
Tom's opening joke.
He's like,
man,
it's a lot of fat people.
He's like,
I heard island life was slope.
I didn't know they were talking about their metabolism.
So then he says I got lost walking around.
Luckily a Japanese guy pointed out the directions.
Those Japanese?
No,
this place like the back of their hand.
I mean he bumps so hard that when he got off he was like debt,
early sweats and he's like,
he's like,
who are pretty good and you might want to go back to your nest and raw.
You know Tom's going to lose he shit.
That video of where I'm shaving Tom.
That's that week?
Yeah.
For after the show.
Before how many shows did you guys do?
One?
Just one in one.
I went up,
I was a little dirty.
I think Tom went up,
had a rough set.
He kind of want them back.
We know Tom is not right for corporate gig in that opinion.
And there's a corporate game gives the,
for the,
it was like maybe I want to say 3000 people on at Pearl Harbor sitting in lawn
chairs with their families.
What was the Gig like?
What,
who is it for?
For the Pearl.
For the USO.
Ah,
that's on,
that's a military guy.
Yes.
Corporate kid will be that same.
Same Energy.
So I,
and so then Tom sits next to me.
This is my favorite part.
Thompson texted me and Russell Peters comes on stage and you can hear there's a
murmuring now mind you,
we're at war with Iraq and Russell Peters is a little brown for their taste.
And Tom Goes,
I never realized he looks like the enemy.
And Russell Peters is by the way,
didn't acknowledge it did had a great set,
but you could hear that kind of like they brought up one of the like and Tom and
I were in the back.
Like this is bad.
We the next day.
Yeah.
He thought it was bad because he was brown.
It was only because we had gone to rifle training the day before and Russell had
randomly chose not to go randomly.
And the first words that rifle training was,
there's one rule here.
If it's Brown,
it moves.
You kill it.
And,
and Tom was like,
thanks guys,
you didn't bring Russell,
let the fuck.
Imagine if you're Mexican and you're in the fucking army and they tell you that
shit.
If it's brown and it moves,
we kill it.
Whoa.
That guy.
And we brought our wives to it.
We,
we've bought arrives to rifle,
we shot every gun they had.
We brought our wives and the girls were like,
right before we went,
stepped in and they go,
can we go to the bathroom?
Or like,
yeah,
go to the bathroom.
So we walk in and the guy's like,
uh,
I thought they were going to be six.
He's like a real military guy.
And we're like,
yeah,
the girls went to the bathroom.
He was okay.
And then Tom goes,
hey,
do me a favor.
When they get in,
act a little like aggressive to them and misogynistic and let's just see,
looks on their faces.
So the girls walk in and he was on,
well,
typical lady's got lost.
Don't know what time it is.
If their man's not next to him.
And Christina and my wife started bubbling like what the,
and he's like,
ladies do follow the men don't know what to do.
Thank you gentlemen.
And he got into character so good that Tom stepped in.
He's like,
it's a joke.
Everybody hits a joke.
He's doing it because we asked him to.
This guy was good.
Wow.
That's funny.
Yeah.
That's hilarious.
It's funny that you can get a trained killer to just crack jokes.
Oh,
that guy was,
it was,
it was a really fun trip.
If it's Brown,
kill it.
it moves you kill it.
The gumption or the gregariousness to break in.
So what are you doing sets or was it I was who?
I don't even know what the fuck I was doing.
I was working out at Barnes and noble.
So you are working at Barnes and noble?
No working out,
working out,
uh,
this bad.
Like you do sets of bonds?
No,
I was working at Barnes and noble and then working out during the day and the
basement.
Like I was fucking,
I got fired from Barnes and noble.
This is the worst I was working at Barnes and noble and astro place.
No fucking AC.
And so everyday I would you ever have a job where you lift boxes and as you do,
you're like,
that's not a bad,
that's a good buy workout.
And you're like,
oh,
all right,
I'll do a little bit of this.
And if I do this all day long,
I'm fucking jacked buys by the end of the summer.
So I'd go down to the basement and you can take the freight elevator.
I'm going to sound like a psycho into five minutes.
You could take the freight elevator to the basement and no one could get down
there cause you had the elevator.
And so once I got to the basement,
I take off my clothes and start working out and just like do pushups,
sit ups,
fucking curls with boxes,
whole books out into fucking these fucking jobs,
front rows and I work out.
And then it was,
there was no AC.
So then I'd wait and I called down,
put all my clothes back on,
getting the freight elevator walk up and I just killed like 30 minutes.
When you have a job like that to kill 30 minutes is a,
it's like fucking calm that much closer to being over done.
So I'm like,
this is,
and I'm eating rip fuel.
You remember ritual pop and fucking three refuels every three hours,
right?
Oh my God.
Like a tweaker running around Shelvin travel books,
going down to the basement,
pounding like I'm in fucking Oz
and then come up sweating like a motherfucker with a name tag on.
Just,
uh,
and so like two weeks into it,
my boss Duane pulls me aside and he was like,
he was like,
Hey man,
you've been spending a lot of time in the basement.
And I was like,
Oh yeah,
cause I got to get travel books and that's where we keep them all down there.
And he's like,
yeah,
do you know we have video cameras?
And I was like,
I didn't know that.
He's like,
you're fucking fired.
And I was like,
wow,
I did Dwayne.
I can explain to you is no I can't,
I can't have someone getting into their underwear basement working out when they
should be working and then coming back up and then interacting with people and I
was trying to be a comic so I was trying to think alternatively and I'm on
speed,
which is Kim.
So theoretically like I would do funny shit,
but it was crazy if you didn't know me exactly.
Some guy told me that the day we were doing a promo shoot phrase Steve TV and I
did a joke at the end of the day like it was that funny.
He goes,
Bert,
everything you do is only funny if you spent fucking 24 hours with you.
And so yeah.
So I got fired and then came home.
I'll be great to have that tape if anyone at Barnes a level.
And so God,
his name is Dwayne.
I remember he asked me if I wanted to be a manager like a week before that and I
was like,
no.
And it was like,
what?
And I was like,
he was like,
you don't want to be manager.
And I was like,
no.
He's like,
why?
Why do you,
what do you want to do?
Then I was like,
I want to be a comedian.
And I was like,
oh,
this isn't what I do.
And he looked at me dead in the face.
He goes,
this is what you do.
This is who you are.
You worked at Barnes and noble.
Don't think you're better than us.
You're not.
Fuck,
I'm out of here soon.
I didn't know I was going to get fired,
but don't think you're better than us with Burke.
Chrysler was telling what I smell might be one of the great stories.
No,
his dad,
no,
he used to shit his pants and all the time.
All the time.
How long would you said the story began with you saying that he shit his pants
in a banana republic in Beverly Hills and uh,
it was,
it was like real,
it was like,
like the real coming of age part of my life when my dad looked at me and he was
like,
buddy,
I'm about to shit my pants.
What do I do?
We use the word,
it's not the,
here's where public have a bathroom,
here's the fucking worst part of it,
right?
So I look at him and I go to shit,
your pants dad,
I think you got to shit your pants and I go,
Shit your pants a little bit and then walk as far as you can and get to your
hotel.
And he just left.
My daughter's with me like fucking dropped on and was like,
I'm fucking out here.
And so he started walking down Rodeo or whatever,
you know,
Burton,
one of those roads to get to his hotel,
right?
So my mom comes up,
she's like,
where's your dad?
And I said,
oh,
he left me this sweater.
I got to buy it for.
I bought them,
ended up buying them the sweater and I go,
he had he shit his pants.
She goes,
what do you mean?
He had his shit,
his pants.
I go,
he ended up,
he had his shit,
so he shit his pants and then he just,
he's walking on the street.
I go,
I'm sure we can catch him.
He's walking slow and then my wife comes up.
She goes,
where's your dad?
And I go,
he shit his pants.
He goes,
why didn't you just use the bathroom?
I said,
where's the bathroom?
She goes downstairs and I went,
Ooh,
I probably should have told him that and so
I didn't know I was in panic mode.
It was black Friday and I'm waiting in line too when I've got a leather jacket
on sale,
but it's even worse I think if you shit your pants in line for the bathroom
because then everybody's going to know if there's a big line of people and you
just blow up is dumping your pants,
then you're like close proximity.
No way to play off shitting your pain when you shit your pants.
I say this shitting your pants is a lot like getting a Dui.
You roll the dice so much and get away with it that when you do get caught with
your hand and cookie jar,
you're like mother fucker and then she never thought that was going to happen.
Are you kidding me?
All the time.
Why today?
Oh that's so true.
When his thirties he was running marathons and he used to shoot his pants all
the time.
Not even like,
I'm not even saying like,
oh once a month.
I'm talking once a week.
He would,
this is before cell phones too.
He was in his thirties he was in his thirties I was a,
I was a kid.
We were living in north Tampa and not in like the nicer north Tampa,
but in the Shittier redneck verse,
Black North Tampa.
And a first time I ever heard her,
the n word was in this neighborhood.
But my dad used to run marathons,
so we'd run like five miles,
10 miles,
and you can go out and on these 10 mile runs,
he shit his pants.
So he go into these orange groves,
shit himself,
right.
Clean himself the best he could and then run home.
But there were some nights,
I remember these distinctly,
it was before cell phones were to get dark and my mom's like,
we've got to go look for your dad.
And we'd be driving his route where he'd run and all of a sudden like a naked
happy.
My Dad would come out of the fucking orange groves.
Like,
I'm here,
give me in the car right now.
If he knew who he come get him,
oh yeah,
it would be.
I remember thundering lightning and he's just sitting in an orange grove naked.
Like,
how did he shit his pants and,
and we'd be like over here and he'd be like,
all right,
and you just hop in the front seat,
go home,
let's go like real quick.
He shit his pants.
He hates my stories.
I hope someone,
if anyone is listening to this,
knows my dad.
Let him listen to this because every fucking story I ever tell he fucking Oise
goes,
God damn,
you're fucking imagination.
I would fuck I did not shit my pants.
I Shit a little bit.
I didn't shit.
You ready to people taking a shit in my pants.
He just squirts.
He's just a little squirter.
I Dunno.
Let's call him on the phone.
Do it just,
I didn't even go lucid.
Like I didn't try to control it or move around.
I just let the dream play out.
But I realized it was a dream and I still didn't wake up.
I have,
that's a rare thing.
Pills just for that shit.
Dreams.
I have dreams,
I have fucking crazy dreams,
but I am totally lucid inside my dreams.
Like all dreams that I'm reading something and I'll go,
I'll be,
I'm going to go.
Wow,
that's so funny that I'm reading something because nothing's there in the dream.
I'll pick this.
Nothing's there in my mind is making up these words,
but I'm still reading them.
That's so interesting.
I had a dream one time that me and Elvis walked into his hotel room and there
were four dudes,
but fucking
right,
and I just hear me where they were.
So just that might be one of the best sentences ever created.
I had a dream that I was with Elvis and we walked into his dressing room.
There was four dudes,
but fucking dot,
dot,
dot.
Now hear me out.
It's weird.
Weirder.
They're throwing up in Burger King cups should
just fucking each other.
And then I swear to you when I say this,
I fucking just shut the door.
And I looked at Elvis.
I go,
what the fuck's going on in your room?
He said to me,
what your dream Baby Shit.
I wake up,
I wake up.
I'm like,
wake up.
Check my Dick and make sure it's on board.
And then I'm like,
well,
you really flipped me out.
You don't really put me out.
Not that,
not that the guys were both fucking right.
That did bother me.
No,
it was the product placement.
Like what the fuck did Burger King do to get it?
If they figured it out,
you just don't know that they are.
It's way to interject advertising into your dream.
It's
burger king in the future.
Right now.
It's like I got her Chrysler stream about the Elvis and the Butt fucking high,
Huh?
No,
no,
no.
But what is,
there's a possibility that someone could insert a product right to a dream,
right?
They could give you a cheeseburger and in that cheeseburger with some
experimental thing that would make you think about burger king in a dream and
see a burger and a dream,
you can do it.
You can do it.
I fucking girl from behind.
It's going Geico and shit.
Yes.
In the future.
But that doesn't make any sense cause you product duck noises.
It's Geico.
Eat something to have this happen to you.
We're still,
we're still missing the whole flag.
We're stumbling on something very brilliant right now.
Can we get to the flag bill those first cause we might forget.
Yes.
Okay.
Calling dildos.
Here we go.
So I called Joe,
this is what you said.
You Go,
we were just talking about this dude like yeah,
you've got so many crazy stories that have happened to you and it and,
and,
but I never think that,
I think there are just things in my life.
I think it's my ability,
the way I see something happen is different than the way everyone else sees it.
You know,
I see the,
the little thing that that registers in me,
I go all,
that's my thing,
you know,
and it lights up for me where my wife just glazes over it and it's come to light
in this podcast more than anything.
The machine,
I mean,
the way I've told the story to fucking a million people,
but then when I told him to do something lit up and I went,
oh,
that is a good story,
right?
The fucking fighting a bear,
the fuck everything.
I'm getting mauled by a bull,
Tracy Morgan,
everything's lights up.
So then I'm talking on the phone today.
I [inaudible] you.
Hey,
can you do by saying I guess and you go,
I said,
I'm on the phone with Delta American Airlines trying to get upgraded.
Your like,
where you going?
I said Amsterdam.
He said,
I've never been there.
I said,
oh,
whatever you do,
if you ever go there,
don't go see flying dildos.
True Story.
Right.
So,
so I'm fucking like 22 Ahmed,
I'm an in Amsterdam,
where would the like five friends and there and of course we do the rounds and
Amsterdam and get fucking lit up.
Heineken factory,
hedge hubs.
I think even maybe my showrooms,
we walked by this live sex show and it says on the billboard guy on girl,
girl on girl oral sex,
uh,
this,
this and then the last one is flying dildos.
Come see flying dildos.
Since all Mike fucking,
I tell everyone we're seeing fine dildos.
I want to see fucking flying deal does.
That to me is a showstopper.
That is something that I will buy tickets for everyone for us.
Why buy us all tickets?
We go in to see a lot of sex or have you ever seen one?
No,
it's basically like,
like half a boxing ring.
So it's like you walk in and it's stadium seating and then half a boxing ring
where they just without the ropes and they just,
everything happens right there.
They just fuck it.
Just fuck and Oh,
and our dudes beating off and the audience,
are you allowed to wear lipstick?
No.
Dudes aren't beating off in the audience.
No,
it's a Chi.
It is kind of creepy now that you say that because I don't know what we were
supposed to do,
but there was like 20 people in there,
but we sat neck yet can,
I guess maybe you should have been,
but we didn't and we ruined it for everyone.
Um,
so we sit down and they're like,
and then they come out and they're like,
the first is,
um,
girl on girl.
This is just like ut a porn,
right?
So two girls come out and they're like,
like they got to eat and just think of two girls come out and start going flying
dildos flying doulos and they're like,
no,
we're not playing dildos.
I go,
ah,
now do any guys are like,
well I want to see flying dildos too.
So they do their thing,
they leave a girl comes out by herself,
masturbation and I go flying dildos and she goes,
no,
I'm not flying dildos.
I fucking,
everyone that came to the stage,
I just yelled,
how many people came to this day?
It's like nine acts,
nine acts coming to the stage.
How about get along is each one doing five minutes and fucking masturbating and,
and then eating each other out and then blowing a dude and then the guy fucks
the girl that's like the headliner,
right?
Like,
and we get to the guy fucking the girl and I'm like,
you better be fucking flying dildos.
And the guys like,
we're not flinging dildos.
Okay.
Stop with the fucking playing dildos.
And I'm like,
I'm like boom.
The whole time they're fucking fuck fucking him.
Yeah.
But,
well now we've got 20 dudes and they're all on my team because they're fucking
hammered.
I'm like,
Ooh,
flying Delta is right.
So then all of a sudden at the dude,
you'll find a lady comes out with a doctor's a little briefcase,
you know the doctor's thing bag and just walks up on stage.
I go,
you better be fucking fine.
Delos because ladies and gentlemen,
I am flying belows and the fucking police like fucking right out of the military
came out.
He goes,
I'm going to need and I'm going to need someone from the audience.
And everyone's like,
oh my fucking,
I am definitely going up there.
Of course he did.
So I get up,
I'm making up there and everyone's chatting,
fine.
Build those fucking dildos.
I got my hands up and she goes,
okay,
okay.
Hands behind back.
And I put my hands behind my back and she handcuffs me and everyone's like
flying dude.
Like everyone's going fucking nuts.
She dropped my pants,
cuts my shirts with the scissors,
throws me on the back,
puts a dildo on my mouth and just fucks it and then stands up.
She goes,
that was flying builders and she leaves me with a Dildo and my mouth naked on
everyone's taking pictures,
like fucking step right up that for like I had handcuffs on,
I couldn't fucking move and just snap,
snap,
snap session and I'm just like,
Oh man,
somebody,
I'll be get to do it out of my mouth.
It was a fucking nightmare.
So we'll have a photo of this.
Uh,
this was in 90.
This is right after the Russian mob thing.
So this is,
there was no digital cameras,
so it's real.
My,
I can tell you if you want somewhere else,
someone out there has an a dusty shoe box.
Pj Cusimano they brought back the tickets.
They're out for bay.
Pj Cusumano has as that picture,
I guarantee it because I know he's one of my,
one of my buddies,
I was on it with us.
He had one of those disposable cameras and came right up there like right up to
the stage and just snap,
snap CJ,
if you're out there,
find me on Twitter homie.
Pj Stansberry the whole time for make it worth your while.
Pj from the comedy store.
So do you ever go to its best PJ face?
I've ever seen him.
Did you,
what'd you give him before the show?
So I have no idea.
I have,
I have no idea.
He's extra silly today.
He is nervous.
Silly.
Yeah.
In Burbank.
There's wild parrots,
like a gang of wild parrots.
I,
yeah,
I've seen them.
Wow.
And they,
it's the loudest thing ever out of nowhere.
It,
it sounds like murder outside of your house.
Whoa.
That's weird.
Yeah.
And if you look online,
there's like websites devoted to him and stuff and they look just like normal
parrots,
but they just go around in this huge gang and just,
that's pretty screen.
I remember we,
uh,
worked at the West Palm Beach Improv,
the old one way back in the day.
And uh,
I,
they put you up at this condo was me and Maddie Kirsch and we looked out the
window and it's fucking like parrots,
like actual parents on this power line.
I'm like,
dude,
there's like real parrots out here.
Yeah.
Like this is the weirdest shit ever.
Like their parakeets and parents.
And I'm like,
these are like tropical birds.
Like Miami's tropics.
It is the tropics.
It is a tropics.
Yeah.
Barely America.
Right.
Let's be realistic.
It's too awesome to be a matter of,
it's too crazy and too,
Cubans got in and just made it tropical.
They've been at tropical.
We're going to Cuba,
Cuba,
do a trip flip Cuba.
Oh Dude.
I want to,
Cuba opened up relations as well as the best thing about the show right now.
Yeah.
I would love to.
Those parakeets are parents.
One of them.
He said the Burbank parrots.
Yeah.
These are actual words.
Actual parents.
Yeah.
They come through him down because of Youtube.
What?
I know these are just still pictures.
Oh,
did they come from people that were,
uh,
that had him as pat,
sir.
What'd they come from?
You know,
there's no,
there's just rumors because Disney's,
there said,
lot of people think that Walt Disney's,
it was Walt Disney's parrots and he just hasn't shown,
we find out they're fake.
They're not powerless.
Walt Disney is such a motherfucker.
He's got fake parents out there flying around.
Shitting on people.
Yeah.
I had a bird,
had bird feeders out I bought recently and they found out about it and now they
won't leave my house alone.
They're there like every day.
Amazing.
Cool Dude.
That's pretty dope.
Yeah.
They're loud too loud that they're annoying as fuck.
No,
you didn't hear plugs on.
Put that.
Let them into your spiritual compass.
Yeah,
bring them into your center.
I will.
That seems like an amazing thing to have in your neighborhood,
man.
Oh,
that's cool.
And it's really cool because it's a,
I live in equestrian place,
so there's horses and parrots.
It must smell awesome.
Horse Shit and bird shit all stood up together.
And the Burbank son.
How is it that it's illegal if you don't clean up after your dog,
but you're allowed to just have your fucking horse shit everywhere.
Empty.
It's giant asshole.
1200 pound body of stewed grasses.
I'm sorry.
Is this cobblestone?
It's just a dirt road.
You farmer.
Fuck.
Pick up after that donkey.
Your donkey.
Just shit all over my Prius.
Your dog does not that green.
This is contributing to global warming.
Donkey was dirty ass.
All.
Brian said he didn't like Paris in his neighborhood.
He's in bed with the chicken.
He's like,
I never said it.
Oh my God.
They're bringing the fucking parrots into the courthouse.
We would now like to call the prosecution witness.
The Burbank Paris never showed us before.
Not Roofing.
What are you talking about?
Are you serious?
Oh,
no,
two heads is fine.
I take two hits all the time and I drive
ingrown hair.
You know,
all you need to do is you need to do with that stuff.
Kills everything.
It'll tell it all.
How about,
how about the,
the defense attorney and the judge was badgering,
badgering the witness in the objection and then brush here.
He goes,
hmm.
Probably want to Greg too far.
Too Far.
Okay.